i think the most
some of the most powerful goals are the
ones that don't have a ceiling
right if you want to make a difference
that doesn't end
and so people set these goals to it's
great to have your sort of intermittent
goals along the way they're sort of
markers in time they allow you to
celebrate along the way but but the
ultimate
manifesto
sort of like
whatever the statement is about what it
is that you're doing whatever your brand
mission is or your mission in general
i don't know maybe you could share your
thoughts around that being something
that doesn't have a ceiling and
therefore can take
the most expansive form
possible
yeah and i think you're right it's it's
something that it becomes more of a
purpose of for you
and your mission of really just as a
human
because i mean if you look at some of
the wealthiest people in the world you
look at warren buffett why does he still
get up and work like
like you have all the money in the world
you're i mean you can literally just fly
around in a private jet and just do the
most exotic things in the world wow all
day every day
all day every day and never have to
stress about money ever well he likes
what he does he likes researching
companies he is he gets a certain
excitement out of that that you don't
get out of doing other things and so for
him it's it's that matter of purpose and
you look at like you know an easy
example to see is just look at shark
tank you have these sharks on shark tank
why are they there they don't need more
money right there they enjoy
entrepreneurship they got to where they
were because they were entrepreneurs
that entrepreneurial energy is something
that you want to be around and so now
you can help other entrepreneurs and go
back into the entrepreneurial energy
another million dollars when you have
100 million dollars doesn't change your
life it doesn't really affect you at all
it's just one of those things where
it's for the purpose the energy and the
fun and the excitement and the impact
that you can make
and i really think you're right where
it's that
no more ceiling it's it's it's now how
you have fun i mean this is like
exciting like
let's go to some nuts and bolts and some
like takeaways some because there's i
would imagine most anybody listening can
sort of maybe they have spent a few
minutes here during this conversation
and intuitively identified some things
that they truly enjoy doing and they're
like man i freaking hate my job that's
what they've realized in the last half
hour they're like i hate my job um and
that's i mean i think that's kind of
exciting so what happens now if you're
someone who
knows what they love maybe you're even
someone who's got the ball rolling a
little bit and on the side you're kind
of playing around with something else
that you love how the hell do you take
that
and
give it the right
nourishment
to grow into something great
like where do you start
so the first thing is going to be so
assuming you have some sort of idea
first thing is you start learning go on
to youtube start reading as many books
as possible uh so watch as many business
entrepreneurial
channels videos that can help you
like any books or so i mean you you have
tons of videos
on your youtube but like any books that
were pivotal for you
uh well a lot of the pivotal books are
real are financial books books related
to investing money management real
estate so i mean if you want to start
there you know robert kiyosaki has a
great book rich dad poor dad balanced
that out with dave ramsey's books on uh
money management they're two completely
opposite
uh opinions of money but they're very
very helpful books um there's tons of
books on anything personal finance but
now when you go to the business side i
nowadays love reading biographies of
people of successful i mean not just
entrepreneurs but really all kinds of
people you hear their story and their
journeys it's not just motivational but
very educational indirectly because you
get to hear what they did from their own
opinions so it's like you know what
would you pay to have lunch with warren
buffett well it doesn't matter what you
pay it's not worth his time
but you know there's books about things
that he did same with richard branson
same with you know most
successful people so read books like
that or if you want more technical books
just go into audible or amazon and look
at the top
25 or 50 business books in a category
buy them all
read them
and there is your mba for less than i
don't know 200 bucks
and i promise you you're going to get
more especially for starting a business
you're going to get more value out of
those books then you will out of trying
to go into a traditional mba that's
going to cost you a hundred thousand
dollars yeah no kidding okay so now you
start learning the second thing you
start doing and so if you have a job
do it in addition to that don't just
quit your job unless you have the
financial resources to fall back on it's
going to be hard because you're going to
say well i'm already working so much and
i got kids and
i know it's hard but this is where
when there's a will there's a way and
this is so true with every aspect of our
lives if you really want to make a
change you will find a way to do it
you'll wake up an hour earlier you'll go
to bed an hour later you will find some
time on the weekends you'll find
sometimes in the middle of your work day
to do something remember it gives you
energy your purpose gives you energy
exactly like you're gonna find a way and
uh you will and so not to start putting
it in an action and
then when you screw up
tell yourself it's okay because that's
the part of the process if you're not
screwing up you're not trying enough
things like you have to make mistakes
you have to screw up but then when you
do screw up learn
start again do it again like i had to go
from business idea to business idea to
business idea to business idea like
again and again and again and again
before i finally found something that
was sustainable for me because
it was how i learned like i screwed up
many times and some of the businesses
that i started did very well
and to stop them when you're like you
know you're making
six figures plus a year and then realize
this is not my passion this is not my
purpose i hate this industry and then
stop it
oh you feel like you're starting over
but this is one of those things where
you know
life is not a sprint it's a marathon
you have time ahead of you and if you
don't do it now two years from now
you're gonna wish what if i just started
two years ago so might as well start now
take little steps and just keep inching
forward and then you'll see oh yeah even
though i screwed up so much i learned so
much i learned how to market i learned
how to sell i learned how to
build something online and it's all a
part of the learning process
and there's no other way to do it
besides just doing it learning screwing
up and doing it again you know we always
assume that oh i don't have a lot of
money to start this idea how am i going
to build it but sometimes that's the
best thing that can happen
um like my minority mindset companies
this whole brand started off with less
than
i don't know 200 bucks because all i
started was making videos off my phone
and then i grew and grew and grew and
now we have a whole team we have
multiple companies under our belt
but one of the things that we tried to
do
was build a blog for minority mindset
the minoritymindset.com now
i was stretched very thin like i was
doing so many different things like i
was building market briefs which is our
newsletter i was working on market
insiders an app that we have i was
building my youtube videos and i was
doing a lot of different things so for
me
building this blog wasn't like
my top priority i had a team for it like
we had some staff members we had
a ton of freelance writers so we hired
one of the top
blog consultants
in the world to
manage and lead and take charge of a
blog and we were playing them paying
them a lot of money like
over i don't remember how much but over
a hundred thousand dollars a year like
at least like on the low end so a lot of
money where you would expect that okay
just turn our blog around give us some
traction
so we paid them a lot of money
and we saw no growth
i think actually our website traffic
went down
and so now
we're hundreds of thousands of dollars
in and now i was like exactly like
okay like yeah
i'm okay financially but this is just
stupid like what is happening here
and so we fired the agency we
uh
really consolidated and we're like okay
what do we need to do to turn this blog
around and so now it's like me investing
my time my energy and building our team
to start researching going back to the
basics
researching learning
implementing failing and trying again
like fail fast this is what they say so
it was one of those things where
you know we did it for a year and
realized this is definitely not the
right direction even though it takes a
long time to build a blog and so we
completely turned it around now we have
a much smaller team
but a
faster growing block and we're growing
way faster than we were before
than when we had all that money going
into it so it's one of those things
where more money doesn't always solve
the problem it's going back to the roots
sometimes and being creative that's
what's exciting about being an
entrepreneur or a bootstrapper when
you're starting with nothing or very
little you gotta figure it out
like when i was in college i was uh
running an event planning company
and i started this because in high
school i was hosting
uh i started off playing the drama
indian weddings
and then when i started working at
indian weddings i got to meet a lot of
the local djs
the djs had this idea for us to host
teen parties when i was in high school
uh at this local restaurant that was
looking for
more exposure because they just opened
so i did that for a little while as a
hobby
but i knew i was like you know this is
just for fun when i go to college i got
to really buckle down and become a
doctor
anyways i go to college not knowing what
to expect
and i see everybody around me partying
drinking doing all this stuff and i was
like well i don't drink i'm not really
into the party scene although i was
hosting the parties but i need something
to do on friday nights so now i'm
knocking on the doors of every club when
you bar restaurant on campus trying to
figure out if i could host a party here
i was 17 at the time
and one club finally said yes you can
host a party here you don't have to pay
us anything just give us fifty percent
of the revenue that you generate the
cover charge i was like all right we're
in business because the previous places
that i talked to we're asking for a
minimum of ten thousand dollars to house
an event and i did not have anywhere
close to ten grand so uh now we were in
business then i found a dj
who was a friend of mine
to work on a commission basis that he
would take fifty percent of the revenue
that i generate so i'm giving 50 to the
club
and then 25 to the dj which leaves 25 to
me but i don't have any costs it was a
way for me to get started and then now
it was all about being creative and
clever with our marketing uh like this
is when facebook used to be very popular
for younger
people like high schoolers and college
people
and so facebook would tell you when
everyone's birthday is and so we would
message everyone's birthday like if the
party was in september we'd message
everybody in september and say hey
because it's your birthday we want to
celebrate we're going to announce your
name at the club at the event and we'll
also give you free entry into the party
now free entry doesn't cost us anything
and shouting you out doesn't cost you
anything but nobody wants to celebrate
their birthday alone you're gonna bring
your closest five to ten friends
and so you know it's just a creative
marketing of how can you now get the
word out without spending
all this money and just figuring it out
because many times we assume that the
reason why we can't become successful is
because we don't have the tool set when
in reality it's we're lacking the
mindset and so we have to work on that
mindset first and then you can build the
tools that after
[Music]